La volta al món a peu, dia 297, continuo a caixgar, continuo sense notícies del visat de Paquistan
i avui havia decidit venir a fer una volteta pel parc principal que hi ha a aquesta ciutat
i no tenia previst gravar, per això no porto ni el trípode, però mira, m'he trobat aquí un munt de gent ballant
es veu que això és una escena bastant habitual, sobretot més aviat a les tardes aquí a la Xina
i bueno, no sé, fa molta caixa, hi ha moltíssima gent, estem parlant que són les 4-5 de la tarda
jo crec que la gent normal que ara està treballant, bàsicament el que hi ha aquí són jubilats
hi ha molta gent jugant a les cartes i també a l'entrada d'aquest parc hi ha una estàtua gegant
de, crec que és Mao Zedong, o Mao, no ho sé, Mao, crec que és aquest senyor, el de la revolució
de la revolució de la revolució de la revolució de la revolució
la revolució xinesa es deia? Bé, no ho sé
molt bé tu, molt ambientillo, jo volia un lloc tranquil per editar un vídeo
i aquest parc està molt bé
A veure, tòpics de la Xina, tòpic és que tot és molt ordenat i que ningú trepitja
la gespa, per exemple, doncs mira, passa igual que a Catalunya, que quan la gent vol anar a un lloc
al final la gent trepitja i es fa un camí natural de no gespar perquè la gent ha trepitjat
Segona estrella útil de la Xina, ping-pong, tothom juga al ping-pong, però sí, hi ha molta gent jugant al ping-pong
i tenen més nivell que a la mitja, jo veig que hi ha bastant de nivell aquí, no tots, no, hi ha alguns amalillos
moltes gent jugant al ping-pong, i tenen més nivell que a la mitja, jo veig que hi ha bastant de nivell aquí, no tots, no, hi ha alguns amalillos
veig que hi ha bastant de nivell aquí, no sé què diuen jugar, és en baralla de pòquer i tots volen fratjo, fratjo i estem a...
estem a 20 i pico, 30 graus, eh? A l'Ombres està bé, aquí el clima és molt sec
Val, aquí sí que hi ha un banc per reposar l'esquena, que és el que estava buscant, i aquí sí que m'empararé a editar el vídeo que volia editar
Bon dia, el dia següent, avui és dimecres
dies de fer poca cosa, passejar, menjar, estar amb els bros, bros que per altra banda ja se n'han, a poc a poc, hi ha un que se n'ha anat al Pakistan, hi ha un que ja se'n va demà, un que se n'ha anat avui
Bueno, avui estic al centre comercial per comprar un frontal, el frontal que tinc del Decathlon té el botó que costa moltíssim de petar i està com mig trencat
i he vist, l'altre dia vaig anar al Decathlon, aquí, es diu Camel, el Decathlon xinès, està super bé aquesta botiga, vaig comprar...
uns mitjons i uns bòxers de molta qualitat, com no havia comprat des de feia molt temps, és a dir, coses que dius, ostres, això va bé, això és material sintètic, molt bé, anem a veure si hi ha frontals, en principi sí
Com s'està pagant el frontal?
Ja el tinc, 5 euros amb 50
Bueno, eh...
doncs els botons...
s'apreten molt fàcil
m'agradaria saber si hi ha alguna manera de que no, doncs, no quedi encès sense voler apretar el botó si està a vegades dintre la motxilla, no, que l'altre sí que en aquest sentit era tan difícil d'apretar que era molt segur
Bueno, no, està bé, està bé
M'agrada, sembla molt gran i sembla molt pesat, però no, eh, és com molt lleuger
Potser el que tenia jo era més lleuger, eh
Però bueno...
Crec que me'n compraré algun per internet i faré com el pàgina arribar amb altres coses que m'han de fer arribar, però això ja quan estigui a la Índia o el que sigui
De moment aquest, perfecte
Dia 299 de la volta amb una peu, avui és dijous i com ja portem molts dies a Caixgar una mica avorrits hem decidit anar fins a Jhurtan o algo així, que és un poble que està una hora i mitja en tren
És molt d'hora, són les 9, bueno, en fi, els trens xinesos aquí s'ha d'estar una hora abans...
Hi ha un munt de gent, el tren és molt llarg
Veieu on estem?
Asseguts aquí, ah, i aquí hi ha lliteres
Bueno, ens va recomanar un noi anglès que porta aquí un mes esperant el Pirat d'Apakistan, que va venir aquí i diu que el poble aquest era interessant
A veure què hi ha
Doncs ja hem arribat, ens trobem a Jharkand, seria el nom en uigur d'aquesta ciutat en cinès Satche o algo així
Bueno una altra vegada ens trobem una antiga ciutat a Jharkand, és una ciutat molt amenaçada per a la gent que ve aquí a Jharkand.
altra vegada ens trobem a una antiga ciutat
de la Ruta de la Seda, el mateix de sempre.
Però, bueno, aquí sí,
va haver-hi...
És ja documentació d'aquesta ciutat
des del segle I abans de Crist
i va arribar a ser un estat independent
durant 200 anys, des del
1500 fins al 1700
va ser un estat independent format
per un descendent de gens iscans.
I, bueno, durant una època
va ser budista i després
va ser islàmica i, com podeu veure,
aquí tenim aquest rotllo
madrassa
d'Uzbekistan en format petit.
Molt maco.
Bueno, anem a fer un cafè primer de tot,
que és d'hora.
Ja tenim aquí el cafè.
Tot és barat, de moment, el que he vist a la Xina.
El tren també havia costat 28 yuan,
que són 3 euros i pico,
una hora i pico, dos, de tren,
comparat amb el tren de Barcelona-Terrasse,
per exemple, que allò, a vegades,
el billet senzill era en 6 euros.
De nada, o sigui, bogeria. O anar i tornar.
Nada, només crec.
Bueno, doncs no, el cafè no. El cafè és
car, cappuccino, 25 yuan, que són això,
uns 3 euros.
Però, bueno, com tota la resta és barat, doncs està bé.
Bueno, jo no sé què m'esperava
d'aquest poble. M'esperava una cosa,
un poble petit, re,
quatre casetes, és un poble oigur,
llavors, no sé, diferent, però no, no, no,
edificis alts, carrers
amples. De fet, no ha sigut idea meva
venir aquí. He vingut amb una
catalana, que m'he conegut
al hòstel, que no vol sortir al vídeo,
té vergonya. Ara vol sortir?
Bueno, diu Jordina.
Hola.
Ara m'ha fiat aquí una mica.
Jordina, que estàs viatjant a la Xina
des de fa uns
20 i escaig dies. Sí, 22 dies.
Vaig començar a Pekín i vaig
anar agafant trens, seguint la
ruta de la seda, fins ara a Caixgar.
Molt bé. Quin és el lloc
que t'ha agradat més? Ja que estem, et fan
preguntes. Uf, així com és
xulo. Bueno,
moltes coses. El desert de Gobi
és al·lucinant, i
després de Gobi, a Turpan, vas
passant altres deserts, que no recordo
el nom, però tots tenen la
seva peculiaritat i realment
és molt interessant. I l'interessant
de la ruta és que, bueno, vas com
aprenent tota la ruta,
tota la història de la Xina, com va entrar
el budisme en aquest país i
tot el tema dels comerciants,
com funcionava la muralla, perquè hi ha
diversos trams que hem passat per la
muralla, que no és la típica
de Pekín, sinó com la
més part d'aquí del desert del Gobi
i és molt interessant.
I el que més m'ha interessat del que m'has dit
és que aquesta part de la Xina
no sembla la Xina. No,
aquesta part no és la Xina.
Per què? Què és el que diries que destaca
més, la diferència més gran? Bueno,
influència uigur, bueno, influència no,
és que són uigurs i sobretot la part
ja de l'altra, d'aquests últims
dies que he anat més cap a Pakistán,
tota aquella zona que ja són
els tajics que, bueno, que ja
van vestits amb la
seva roba autòctona,
no, no tenen res a veure
amb els xinos.
Molt bé, però turistada històrica,
d'això també. Típiques botigues
de souvenirs,
em sembla que és gar.
També hi ha guiris,
les rodes aquestes de carro,
la fusió d'instruments.
El postre que es gasten en aquest país
és tomatge.
Ara ve la Golden Week,
que és que de l'1 al 7 d'octubre
és festa nacional i tanca tot.
Tanca fins i tot totes les fronteres terrestres.
Per tant, jo no puc creuar a Pakistán de l'1 al 7
d'octubre, encara que m'arribi el visat.
I havia pensat de dir, bueno,
no et quedis a Kasgar, no, és una altra banda.
Però és que tot puja de preu,
tot està superocupat, val el doble.
Kasgar és una zona que encara està una mica
més tranquil·la, perquè està com lluny de tot.
I se m'estan traient les ganes,
jo crec que em quedo a Kasgar. De fet,
per si de cas, he agafat un allotjament
amb cancel·lació gratuïta, per si no m'arriba
el visat, doncs m'he de quedar a Kasgar.
Doncs, bueno, com a mínim tindré
lloc a un altre hostel.
No tot és tem turístic,
també hi ha aquesta masquita que hem trobat,
com bastant antiga, el que passa és que,
fixa't, per començar està tancada,
i en segon lloc, a l'entrada hi ha com
aquests fanalets xinesos que no pinten res aquí.
És com dient,
això és nostre, també.
Val, ara ens hem trobat això aquí, que és la
menció de Satya, que és una espècie
de, bueno, reconstrucció
de la ciutat.
Molt moderna, del que
seria aquesta zona
en una altra època.
Jo no ho acabo de veure. No sé si això
ha sigut així en qualsevol moment. De fet,
és tan fake que els arbres
són de plàstic.
El 1750
aproximadament va ser quan
la dinastia Qing,
Qing amb Q, i acabat amb G,
va arribar aquí a
aquest poble, que no recordo el nom,
i, doncs, bueno, es van establir
aquí i van conquistar la zona.
La dinastia Qing eren del nord-est
de la Xina.
Manxús, se'ls diuen.
Us sona el terme Fu Manxú?
Doncs els Manxús. I van estar
governant, de fet, tota la Xina fins al
1911. No confondre
la dinastia Qing
amb la dinastia Qin. És que això
és un... La dinastia Qin
són molt famosos. Són, per exemple, els que van fer
els guerrers de Xi'an,
de Terracota, famosos. Aquests no són
els que van estar aquí. Aquests són els Qin.
Aquí eren els Qin. Bé, no t'ho...
És igual. Parada per
dinar, uns dumplings molt bons.
La Jordina
de carbassa, perquè és vegetariana.
Jo, d'anyell,
de xai, molt bons. Mentre, de fons,
vallen...
Veieu un home allà, dos homes,
i la gent els mira. Una mica
se m'ha de cascar, però amb menys gent.
Molt raro.
Ja ho hem vist tot, i ara toca esperar
dues hores al tren. Així que
aprofitem. Escolta,
Jordina, tu que ets vegetariana, com portes
en aquest país el tema
de la teva dieta?
Complicat. Sobretot a la part
de Xinjiang.
Xinjiang és carn.
Carn tot, i si no, els vegetarians
tenim l'opció dels espaguetis
freds. Dolentíssims.
Bé, només que ara que els acabes
avorrint.
I el tren?
Hi ha altres llocs millor?
Avui dia has menjat bé, trobes, aquest viatge?
Sí, hi ha llocs que he menjat molt bé, però igual...
Avui he menjat bé, els dumplings aquests amb carbassa.
Sí, dumplings de carbassa.
L'única opció. I a resta de la Xina
hi ha més opcions vegetarianes,
però és just.
Quin diries que ha sigut el plat estrella
d'aquests gairebé 30 dies
que portes creient?
Els dumplings avui de carbassa estaven bons.
I després, a Datong
tenen uns espaguetis així,
com unes tallarines gegants,
que per menjar-les amb els palillos
és molt complicat,
però no sé com es fan, però estan bons.
Aquesta nit et porto
a un lloc
que potser serà el teu millor àpat de la Xina.
M'atreveixo a dir que sí,
perquè allò on vaig anar l'altre dia va ser brutal.
Dintre vídeo.
Bueno, bueno.
Flipeu amb el lloc aquest, eh?
Flipeu amb el lujo.
Mireu, mireu, mireu, mireu, mireu.
L'escala és ja... L'entrada és molt lluny.
El restaurant ja és... Pum.
Però és que fixa't, perquè
dins del restaurant, avui hi ha molta gent, eh?
Hi ha...
Hi ha un piano de cua.
Fa!
Hi ha una font. Hi ha...
Cantaires.
Hi ha làmpares d'aquestes
de sostre... No sé com es diuen.
Aranya?
És una passada, eh?
Una passada.
Estarem a l'squí.
relationes i
Camerير Jo juro que
La gent està preciosa.
Estem aquí amb els bròs i les bròs, som sis.
Brutal.
I tenim un noi que es diu Kai,
que he lives in Sweden,
but he is Chinese, so he help us order.
So can you tell us more or less what you ordered,
because it was you.
I have to wait for the dish to come, you know.
Some tofu, really good tofu,
and then mushrooms, and what else?
Some fish?
Egg rolls, fish, your fish,
and I can't remember, I have to see the dish.
I'm very hungry. Good.
Doncs ja està, ja hem sortit, ja hem acabat.
Hem menjat bé o què?
Molt bé. Una barbaritat.
Molt bo.
I molt menjar, i ha costat,
tenint en compte que hem demanat tès,
hem demanat també cerveses,
12 amb 60 per persona.
Fa!
Molt, sí.
Bé, ara són les 11 i mitja, d'aquí mitja hora començo el directe,
i demà és un dia important, que és la festa de...
Festa de mitja tardor.
Bé, festa de mitja tardor o alguna cosa així,
una festa molt, molt, molt important a la Xina,
la documentaré i la veureu en vídeo.
Fins demà, passat per vosaltres.